hallo leute ich es wieder eure ariel und
willkommen zu einem neuen text video
heute testen wir eine wirklich riesige
box die ist so schwer mit abgelaufenen
und kaputten süßigkeiten ich weiß nicht
genau was das bedeutet ich fand es mega
spannend und ist muss ich sie an stellen
also diese box hatten waren wert von 100
euro ich habe sie aber für 59 90 gekauft
das ist sie dafür war das gute ding mal
auf die ist wirklich sehr sehr
schwerfällig dann wahrscheinlich ein
gewicht von gewicht würde ich 20 kilo
einschätzen
also ich find's cool wenn wir jetzt
abgelaufene sachen drin sind das die
halt nicht im müll landen und man sieht
billiger kaufen kann und kaputte sachen
den aspekt finde ich schon mal mehr gut
aber also für 100 euro die box weil die
dreckigen drauf es ist nicht drei kilo
ok also start weg dabei so sieht es aus
wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an oder das
erste produkt da haben wir eine
schokolade gar kein zucker kein zucker
drin nur stevia belgische
milchschokolade aber was mich gerade
wundert ist was ist jetzt deren warum
wird das die es seit über einem monat
abgelaufen aber es ist nicht schlimm als
schokolade und man unterstützt project
cacau würde ich mal sagen probieren wir
dass wir vergessen heute malt alle
miteinander dass ich eine
laktoseunverträglichkeit habe und
probieren diese schokolade also sie
dabei sehr süß finde ich auch gut wenn
man so eine kleine tafel hat kann man
die essen und die andere bleibt noch
geschlossen
wie schmeckt wie eine ganz normale
schokolade das sagen sie fühlt sich
dünner im mund an hat sie dann weniger
kalorien dadurch den hat 86 pro 100
gramm kokain irgendwas mit verstehe ganz
viele
zucker das wie viele von denen die eine
seite ist zucker und wie andere ist so
ein holzstäbchen zum umrühren für ein
café a1 nicht plastik meine zucker seite
ist super ich finde nur diese plastik
seite hat wozu braucht man das das ist
weder ein kaputtes produkt noch ein
abgelaufenes das ist einfach nur das
haben die wahrscheinlich da im büroraum
gehabt also jetzt kann man immer was
umrühren 20 stück oder so sind das
machen wir weiter
ich sehe ich aus wie arielle und das
pony zur seite genommen habe
[Musik]
als nächste geschmack erdbeere der
besten beziehungsstatus nicht gerade so
aus schreibt in die kommentare
natürlich möchte ich den auch noch
probieren ja schmeckt halt nach zucker
mit erfahrungen machen wir mit den
nächsten weiter ok guck mal yes that's
what we're talking about hier sowas ist
doch teil bestand diesen gut
das nächste was wir sind super rhabarber
box bei morgens kennt ihr diese videos
wie diese sachen produziert werden dann
haben die immer so eine große
zuckerstangen und dann immer darauf
runde mit diesem kleinen stücke daraus
werden so satisfied karies und komik
das nächste wird an die total freuen
jake and neck er ist der 11.000 21 die
geben eigentlich nur kaputt und ab
gelaufen sagt ist ein ganz normales
produkt ich sehe es nicht kaputt sein
soll
es ist noch bis november haltbar weil
kartoffelstärke sonnenblumenöl natürlich
ein echtes kamel ist eine aus neuses nec
speck your own sweet pizza das ist eine
backmischung wo man sich eine bank
marmelade drauf macht und marshmallows
auf anbrät schmelzen lässt
hier haben wir grüne streusel
marshmallows eine backmischung und ein
beutel eine feste wiederverwendbare form
dass wir in school
vielleicht ist dass er wie so ein keks
so ein käse und marmelade ja das geht
das ist erwiesen kuchen lesungen nur ich
verstehe gerade schon wieder nicht
kaputt war das produkt nicht es ist auch
noch bis zum 10 9 haltbar
ach so aber kann sogar also klar
dreimal das macht doch keinen sinn das
wird an die familie verteilt keine
chance diese ganze woche ist bis jetzt
spannender als ich gedacht hätte ich
dachte jetzt kommen einfach nur snacks
und süßigkeiten aber nein ich meine
als nächstes haben wir hier feine
schokolade die noch lange haltbar ist
und komplett in ordnung ist das ist bis
zum 31
erst 2023 haltbar es ist nicht kaputt
alle spieler haben sind komplett auf
jeden fall zum verschenken who das nicht
gelingt ist auch noch haltbar und
komplett in ordnung also das konzept
dieser box haben die selber irgendwie so
ganz eingehalten tokens mit karamell
diese box wurde wenigstens schon mal
geöffnet toffees für das muster ist auf
kern butter topfen dann ziemlich in
vergessenheit
ich weiß nicht was es genau ist das ist
nicht so dieses englische fudge noch
haltbar
natürlich aber wenigstens habe ich das
produkt jetzt gerade voll verstanden
klar es war schon irgendwie geöffnet
dann haben sie noch mal geschlossen und
packen es damit rein weil das sind noch
gute lebensmittel kann man aber nicht
mehr so normal verkaufen
das nächste
nummer kekse die völlig in ordnung welt
und im august ablaufen
vielleicht sieht es schon auf denen
steht cocktails ohne alkohol die riechen
eigentlich wiederum kugel mit kakao
topix mit creme rom geschmack ich
verstehe süßigkeiten mit
alkoholgeschmack nicht da sind ok in der
box haben sie aber auch wieder mit halo
ist denn schon weihnachten unser
nächstes produkt ist ab wie vox bonbon
25 den ersten 23
die haltbar diese box ist wirklich
wirklich kaputt des wichtigsten zitrone
hier
ich möchte nicht mal gut als er ist
nicht mein bruder zitronengeschmack ja
dafür bekommt man aber auch einen mangel
handtuch
aber die tour bis von 100 prozent
recyceltem material wurde aus strich aus
erdbeeren ich habe noch nie marmelade
aus einer tube gesehen
das programm greift keine marmelade
kommen wir zum nächsten produkt und das
ist trommelwirbel
[Musik]
noch mehr zucker kirsch banane lecker
was befindet sich in der nächsten
eingepackten sneakers tina bara danke
[Musik]
war kein schutz
ich dachte gerade ich brauche hertel um
das zu probieren
praktisch wir haben schon vorgedacht
dies kann sogar irgendwie normal
erdnussbutter gar nichts süßes oder
besteht mit karamell geschmack und mit
schokoladenstückchen aber ganz normal
unser nächstes produkt ist ein
handgemachter lolli der auch noch bis
oktober haltbar ist und völlig in
ordnung ja gut ich weiß wie das
schmecken wird es mir kalt es nach
zugang
das werde ich verschenken als nächstes
haben wir kaufrausch pillen mit
schnäppchen blogger für kaufsüchtige
mädels die sich mal wieder zu viele
schuhe holte kam zu fall
mit diesem produkt habe ich gestern erst
geträumt hubba bubba mit cola geschmack
nicht abgelaufen möchte oder das gleiche
nochmal mit kirschgeschmack toll da
haben sie doch was pop charts
die finde ich mega gut frosted cinnamon
roll ich bin ein riesen fan von
schnecken
was ist denn jetzt am ablauf august
nicht kaputt auf dieser schokolade sind
vogel drauf und auf der packung steht
milch schokolade gefüllt mit dem fiskus
ihre und sie kommt aus der schweiz dass
schokolade hammer
das ist teuer es ist als ob man eine
short essen würde es ist irgendwie
lecker ich weiß nur gute schokolade ist
es auf jeden fall eine erfahrung wert
als sein bruder vor die kühlbox
[Musik]
ich denke das sind jetzt wieder
irgendwelche baum bauen
ich kenne marinic lakritz muss man halt
mögen aber es gibt ganz viele pluspunkte
für diese wunderschöne box der beute
love eine bäckerei kennt man man liebt
ist abgelaufen lasse ich jetzt auch noch
zu dann können wir die auf machen wenn
wir die auch möglich essen wollen oh
mein gott hinterließ grad so ein
schneesturm trainig um what the [ __ ] wie
das peitsche oder das wetter spielt
verrückt leute weg mich wachmacher kraft
bonbons also das sind bonbons mit
guarana koffein und taurin enthält 200
milligramm koffein auf 100 gramm bot die
mich jetzt nicht zu verlieren zu zittern
darüber freue ich mich gerade sehr dass
in meiner absoluten lieblings kekse die
teilnehmer im türkischen laden die sind
mit so einer marshmallow creme gefüllt
keks und schoko außen aber auch noch
mehr haltbar
mittlerweile geben wir auch auf dass
diese box irgendwie einen sinn hat wir
sind uns wohl alle einig dass sich 60
euro zum fenster rausgeschmissen haben
ich hab mich vertan das in die gleichen
täter sind türkischer laden sind einfach
ganz normal die kekse mit schokolade und
wird aber irgendwas was machen sie mit
dem geschmack also schmeckt einfach
anders laufen aber auch noch nicht auf
also als nächstes haben wir ein
hilfsmittel augen
da ist mir schon was entgegen gesprungen
diese wassermelonen vcd kennt die sind
da drin und so saures zeug und er klar
es musste ja da drin sein dürfe nicht
vergessen ein kleines radiergummi tja
entscheidet selbst wann wir mit dem
nächsten weiter hier haben wir nest
komisch aber alles gut es hat nur zwölf
gramm zucker pro 100 gramm
es gibt aber von der türkischen keks
marke blue chip cookies denken weil ich
schmecken genauso geil wie alle anderen
auf und zuvor letzter eine packung 22
packung lisa kugler min
die haben halt so eine zucker größte um
die schokolade herum bis jetzt nicht die
blätter süßigkeit aber man kann es auf
jeden fall essen zum traumfinale machen
wir jetzt hier unser über kuba auf mann
war das ein fantastischer test von
exquisiten sachen weil sie so süß kann
man machen so leute die box ist leer ich
habe alles durchprobiert es ist eine
spannende box gewesen es sind aber so
viele produkte drin gewesen die sich gar
nicht gelohnt haben also ich meinen beim
besten willen wer ist denn so viele von
diesen bonbons und das finde ich ein
bisschen schade dass das so abgeschickt
wird und halt ein bisschen enttäuscht
und es waren viele produkte drin gar
nicht abgelaufen waren und auch gar
nicht saisonal und gar nicht kaputt wo
ich nicht so ganz den sinn dahinter
verstehe also hast auch wenn ihr
irgendwelche mystery süßigkeiten boxen
kaufte am ende ist es halt wie mit einem
mystery boxen die hälfte träsch drin und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder entspanne gaming wanne letztes
video ein anderes video und hier könnt
ihr mich aber nie ran
ich gucke mir zweiter den schneestürmen
bei